there are currently over 4 000 games
available for the playstation 4 and
99 of those will work on sony's shiny
new playstation 5 consoles
but will we keep our saves how is it
going to work
well here's how and all the benefits
that will come from playing your ps4
games on ps5
but first let's talk about which ps5
you'll be playing those games on
if you get a ps5 digital edition that's
the one without the disk drive you'll
only be able to play
digital versions of compatible ps4 games
that you've bought
via the playstation store it makes sense
you can't put a disk in if there's no
disk drive
if you have a ps5 with a disk drive you
can play digital versions you own
or use your ps4 disks as long as it's in
the drive
easy so what's it going to be like
playing ps4 games on ps5
well select games will be able to take
advantage of game boost and have quicker
loading times and
improved and more stable frame rates the
first confirmed example is ghost of
tsushima
which will now be playable at 60 frames
per second and the loading times will be
much quicker
remote play allows games to be streamed
from ps4 to ps5
but if you do so it won't provide any of
the benefits of game boost
since the new dual sense controller is
replacing the dualshock 4's share button
with the create button
you can't use the share menu when
playing a ps4 game on ps5
but you will still be able to take
screenshots if you're playing a ps4 game
on ps5
playstation support suggests that you
test out the game on the ps5
before you buy any dlc for it on the
playstation 5.
sony is currently being a little cagey
about its new user interface but some
games will be able to take advantage of
that too
you can play psvr games on ps5 but the
ps5 camera won't work for psvr
you need to use the playstation camera
for ps4 and the free adapter
but what about transferring my saves
well don't worry any ps4 saves you have
in the cloud
will automatically sync with the ps5
you'll also be able to transfer not only
your saves but your game data
and even digital games from your ps4 to
your five
using wi-fi or a lan cable if you've got
data from your ps4 on a usb hard drive
you can plug that straight into the five
but beware
if you're playing the same game but
going from a ps4 version to a ps5
the ability to transfer your saves is a
developer decision
and will vary between titles so make
sure you check
dirt 5 yakuza like a dragon and
spider-man remastered have already
confirmed that they won't support
cross-gen
saves speaking of upgrading from a ps4
to a ps5 version of the same game here's
how to do
that if you're upgrading a digital
version of the game
sign in to your ps5 find the game you're
looking to upgrade in the playstation
store
and find the upgrade offer and it'll
download if you're upgrading a disk
version
insert the disk head to the game hub and
download the upgrade
now even though you've upgraded you'll
still need the disk in the system every
time you play
some games will be able to be upgraded
for free others
may incur a cost but it will be
discounted from buying the game at full
price on ps5
i already said 99 of ps4 games will work
on the ps5 so which ones won't
the list is actually very short right
now including such titles as robinson
the journey and hitman go definitive
edition
sony has a page on its support site that
will be constantly updated with games
that won't work on ps5
so that's how ps4 games will work on ps5
we've got a roundup of all the other
coolest features on sony's brand new
console right here on gamespot thanks
for watching
[Music]
you